نحن نعيش باستمرار
في تفاوضات صعبه تفاوض معدات تفاوض مع
اللغه كنا نتكلم عن ذلك قبل قليل
التفاوض على الحياه كيف
نعيشها وكيف نختمها
وتفاوض في الحياه المشتركه ما يدهشني
احيانا اليوم ارى في الوضع الراهن وفي
الحياه الاجيال الحديثه ضغوط تفاوضات لا
تنتهي
لانه
مجتمعتنا خضعت لنوع من اعاده التقليديه
دائما اعطي مثلا عن ذلك بكون
جيلي مثلا تزوج في اطار علاقات
داخل الجامعه وبعد ذلك كانت هذه الزيجات
بسيطه ولم
لم تلجا الى الاساليب التقليديه على
الاطلاق هلا الجيل نعم ابناء جيلي
يدعونني اليوم في حفلات تزويج ابنائهم على
طريقه القرن التاسع عشر يعني شيء لا يصدق
كيف نعود الى احياء التقليديه من جديد
ولذلك فالشباب مضطرون اليوم للتفاوض على
كل شيء يوميا ونحن معهم ايضا ولو اننا اقل
شبابا فاننا نفاوض المجتمع على ما يسمح به
وما لا يسمح به نفاوض الحاكمين على ما
يسمحون به وما لا يسمحون به نفاوض انفسنا
على العالم نسمح به لانفسنا وما سنسمح به
لانفسنا وهذا ما يعبر بشكل جيد على اننا
بالرغم من التقدم المادي الذي نعيشه فان
على مستوى
السلوكات والقيم لا نتقدم كثيرا
هناك تقدم ولكن ليس هناك تغيير ليست مجرد
كلمه نعم محتوى هو اعمال العقل هو الحريات
الفرديه هو الاختيار الحر هذا هو التقدم
التقدم بنيه على الانجازات العلميه
والتكنولوجيا وعلى الانجازات في المجال
القيمي ايضا